[Music]
king e3
from oh really
play the scandinavian and you are
so rude i suggest offering me that pun
so this is this is a bit
funny uh that if my pawn was on c5 this
would be a budapest gambit
in reverse um
what do i play against the buddhist
gambit
okay not f6 bishop c4 e6
that's a little bit dull because he will
he will probably regain the pawn with
with a with a slightly worse position
and where's the fun in that
okay i will try and play aggressively
because why not f5
knight g3 i don't know if fe4 was a
big threat there maybe bishop c bishop
c4 queen d4
probably the point is if fe4 queen h5
could be
could be nasty um anyway
gotta play speaking of nasty maybe f4
oh there's not h5 so
um yeah okay
think the logical way here is once again
to push push them pawns clearly i'm not
going to be able to
to castle queen uh kingside here very
soon anyway
so there's no reason not to
[Music]
oh not to e2
it's it really is as though my opponent
is
just trying to set out to to surprise me
okay i'll go queen d6
if knight c3 i would have had to go a6
um
so he should have included knight c3
now i can just develop castle
uh and the knight nh1 is awful i have
um i have a space advantage as well uh
the only
problem is that i don't have a lot of
time
but i think i should have enough to um
to con convert the um
[Music]
considerable advantage that i have here
knight b4 seems to win a pawn uh
bishop f6 push f6 knight d5 cannot be
prevented
and then i will be um pawn up
better control in the center and
better minor piece
better major pieces as well in short
life is good
uh yeah queen a4 is quite logical
i guess bishop c5 developing while
um uh
protecting something the pawn on a7 he's
got
b4 bishop b6 c4 but then i go rook d4
and if c5 that bishop takes c5 because
of the pin on this queen
so we can't actually um do anything too
aggressive here uh yeah i guess i'll
just take on d1
and f4
um creating a possible threat of f3
also roof g8 can be played later on
um queen e4 is a good move
i guess i'll just go f5 though yeah
and now i can just trade
because oh oh oh oh oh
i thought there was a background mate
but he could have taken on c5
and he had a square on h2 that was
insane
no that was that was i don't know what
that was
that was really bad this was instructive
though his knight is no squares
no that was that was incredible
so i have 30 seconds to convert or
29 now should be should be plenty
we'll just walk the king over his king
has no there's no squares bishop d4 may
be coming as well
and uh yeah queen king h5 is a good
pre-move
because uh the only way he could try to
trick me was knight g3 and
king h5 would not be illegal in that
case
you know explaining it to you not only
about
the chess but also about primo trickery
and so on
okay he resigns and uh that seems uh
justified
okay a decent game except from
[Music]
uh from one really really bad hiccup
there